my car got stolen and oh yeah what
because you left the keys in it no no I
didn't do that
I got a um a notice from the city of La
saying that I had a delinquent parking
ticket and you're like all right now
you've crossed the line yeah don't get
tickets in my name it said the address
and I googled the address and there was
a guy who runs a small business out of
his apartment a locksmith and I called
him I said uh hey I know this is weird
but my car was stolen and I just got a
notice that there was a ticket issued to
it at your address have you noticed a
silver Volvo parked out he goes oh my
God yes and I got all excited he's like
I remember seeing it and thinking hey
this guy's gonna get a ticket
I said is it still there and he said I
don't know my wife is home I'll ask her
to look and he asked her to look and it
wasn't there no so they parked it and
then like continued driving it these